[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chris mannix
joined us yesterday on short notice
after we learned that danny ainge
stepping down
brad stevens stepping up and uh chris
wanted some answers to some questions he
got a chance to take part
in the press conference yesterday and uh
chris on loan from sports illustrated
their senior writer
with the nba chris um i feel like i know
less today than i did yesterday how do
you feel about this situation
well i think i know or maybe no is the
wrong word
um i feel a little more comfortable with
certain aspects of this
specifically i'm less certain
that brad stevens would have been back
as head coach if he wasn't elevated to
this job
and that was the question i asked brad
yesterday you know would he be
comfortable and happy going forward
just as the head coach and look he
answered in the affirmative
but if you listen to the answer it
wasn't you know kind of a
resounding yes you know to that that
question so
i i wonder about that now i do think
if the celtics had hired sam presti
as they probably should have uh he would
have
had convinced brad steven to be needed
convincing to stay on the relationship
between those two
is rock solid but if it had just been
anybody else an internal promotion
mike zaran the assistant gm there i
don't know maybe you would have stuck
around for a year but i don't know if he
would have been as committed
as he's been for the last eight years as
the head coach
i just don't know if they strengthen the
organization if ainge steps down and
then you take your coach
and then you put him into the front
office and his first job is to then hire
a coach
to replace him they had one of the
bright
young coaches in the nba they did
and a coach that despite a rocky last
few years
was still widely regarded by his peers
as a top five coach uh
top ten however you want to frame it in
the nba
and now they begin a coaching search for
his replacement
while he is running the front office as
a novice i i
completely agree with you i don't i
don't know how you can look at the
situation objectively
and say the organization improved now
who he hires as coach will influence
that opinion but
i know i sound like a broken record dan
with the sam presti stuff but
that's the best gm in basketball who
grew up in suburban massachusetts
who probably views the celtics as his
dream job
where's the phone call where where is
the aggressiveness why
why did this move need to happen right
now i
i i don't think brad stevens is worse
than
you know other candidates i'm
specifically only talking
about sam presti an elite general
manager who was available i don't know
why
that conversation didn't take place but
was there a chance that brad stevens was
not going if he didn't move
up like was he given a hey we need you
to move up because danny's
age is retiring no
um to hear whit grossbeck explain it
and to hear people behind the scenes
sort of talk about it it wasn't a
you got to do this it was danny's idea
i believe first and brad stevens
eventually warmed to it
i don't think i don't think you can
understate dan
how or overstay rather how much how
important and influential
the last three years has been on this
decision if the celtics had been
conference finalists or nba finalists
over the last three years with no issues
whatsoever
i think brad stevens might be more
motivated to stay on that job if he saw
a championship light
at the end of the tunnel but 1819 was
brutal
last year was the bubble season which
was stressful and this year had so many
problems so
if you're brad stevens you know maybe a
break
feels good for you as i said to you
yesterday you can always
if you're brad stevens go back to
coaching like that that opportunity will
be available to you
this this might not be so i completely
understand
why brad stevens jumped on it again the
question is
why the celtics without conducting a
deeper search offered it
it'd be like me going into the front
office at espn
to then oversee all of the sports center
anchors
it doesn't it just doesn't what i do
well is
anchor sportscenter not overseas
sportscenter anchors i just
something's missing here that that's all
it is it is a well
look the one of the overriding factors
is the regard in which celtics ownership
holds brad stevens i mean
all the public clamoring for brad
stevens job over the last couple of
years has been nonsense
because ownership firmly believes in him
and firmly believes in his basketball
acumen so
i don't again i don't think another
organization would have offered brad
stevens this job
but the celtics because of how much
respect they have for him
they believe that he can do it but
you're right
it it is a mixed bag with this stuff
right like pat riley
certainly did it exceedingly well yeah
danny ainge
did it exceedingly well both those guys
are ex-players but i don't know if
that's as relevant as
as it used to be uh so but there have
also been
the flip side i mean tom thibodeau was
an abject disaster
as the head coach at the gm of the
timberwolves there are other examples of
coaches jumping into that that situation
and not doing well so
it's hard to to gauge how well it's
going to go for brad stevens with
with all with these results that we know
about around the league he's chris
mannix the senior writer
sports illustrator covering the nba um
who's in worse shape
lakers or clippers well because we don't
know
the status of anthony davis and because
their elimination game comes first i
guess you'll say the lakers
in this uh in this situation um
i you know look i picked the suns to win
on the show before uh i didn't think
they'd win like that
i didn't think they'd come out and just
storm the lakers in that game and
if davis plays i i can't imagine him
being close to 100
and the presence of chris paul in that
lineup i think will mitigate
kind of the overwhelming feelings those
teams those players will feel
uh being in a close-out type of game so
i'm going to say the lakers but man
can the clippers do anything to stop
luca doncic when he's when he's right
like
i don't i heard you say lucas numbers
what makes those numbers that much more
remarkable
is that he's done all against the
clippers and he's done it
entirely against two elite defenders
like kawhi leonard
and paul george he's not going to go up
against many better defenders
than those guys in the post season so
add that to the remarkableness
of what what kawhi is doing but you know
it's it's
it's important for the lakers to win
obviously i don't think it affects
lebron's legacy one way or the other but
man
if the clippers bow out in the first
round it uh you know
changes will be a coming in los angeles
that's for sure
let me go back to luca here because i
wonder when the media turns on him that
he puts up these incredible numbers
uh are you gonna get close to winning a
championship like
at what point do we ask for receipts
here where it's
uh hey luca unbelievable performance
um then you're gonna be asking if
let's say they don't make it out of this
round
i mean the media is going to turn on him
at some point and say
you know is he is he too ball dominant
um
yeah like i don't know there's a james
harden russell
westbrook feel of always having the ball
here
yeah i mean there is although he's
very much a facilitator when he has that
ball too i mean he's
an elite passer and i mean porzingis
made a big shot last night but he was
awful for
much of that game you know in general
uh i asked you know ask for proverbial
receipts
when a player has the
has championship talent around him and
i'll make it a comparison here
like donovan mitchell a lot of people
jumped on donovan mitchell this season
you saw the shaq interview where shaq
said you're not the guy other people
have said
something similar i kind of shook my
head at that like
donovan mitchell before this season has
never been surrounded
by championship level teammates so i
never you know it was a bad look to blow
the 3-1 lead in the bubble last year but
it was the bubble they didn't have
bullion buganovic
and mike conley was in and out of that
lineup during that series this year
i want receipts from donovan mitchell
this year i want to see donovan mitchell
at a bare minimum get to the conference
finals if not get all the way
to the nba finals luke is not quite
there yet that's a good team in dallas
tim hardaway has been excellent for them
jalen brunson a revelation
but as they add pieces around him and
they get to that championship level
that's
when you start expecting luca to take
that team to that level
would you ask the question to anthony
davis
about his new nickname and if so how
would you ask that question
i don't even know what his new nickname
is what are we street clothes by charles
barkley
oh i didn't hear that uh no
i would not ask the brow's too good like
why why change
if it ain't broke don't fix it right
well street clothes is not a good
nickname
brow is a oh yeah i mean
the guy i mean this is like i i have
this argument in boston
all the time but like did the celtics
tune out brad stevens well they were in
the conference finals last year so i'm
going to say no
anthony davis is injured a lot but he
won a championship last year so
i don't know i mean it to me it's a
little bit too early to
start tagging with that like chris paul
frankly if chris paul's
uh injury had been more significant
it probably would have reflected more
you know poorly on him than it would
anthony davis because it seems like
every time
chris paul gets on a team that has that
potential an injury comes about whether
it's the
rockets team that was in the conference
finals or this team this year with that
shoulder injury so i think it's
it's more important for chris paul to be
healthy in this series than anthony
davis
oh no anthony davis has to be healthy
because that's bigger picture that they
can win a championship if chris paul's
helping you don't think you don't think
phoenix can can win a championship
uh if anthony davis is healthy no
well i mean look i'm saying if they get
past the lakers
it's kind of a wide open field i mean
how about how about i give you the suns
and i take the field in the way no no no
no no no no no no no i'm i'm taking the
field i think they can't
they can't well you know you basically
eliminated them before they play game
six so i'm just
you know advocating for ricky rubio's
former team
is ricky ruiz right they would have been
right here with ricky ruby yeah they
would have been here
yeah right in boston with you out of the
playoffs
is rubio still in the league uh
yes he's still in the league he was uh
he was uh guiding the timberwolves
i can't even finish that sentence is
that the worst organization
uh no because i think gerson rosas
taking over
a year ago starts to turn it in the
right direction
but no i mean i think
you know cleveland looks like they're in
worse shape but do you think minnesota
is staying that the timberwolves will
stay in minnesota
even no i don't i don't and this is
again this is pure speculation on my
part but
you know glenn taylor getting caught
with his pants down
in that lawsuit where there's you know
no language in that contract
that says yesterday by the way dan and
you know this like
even if there is language in that
contract it's unenforceable like you can
find
a loophole that says well you know we
lost money here so we got to move the
team like there's no
there's no key to any language there if
you're a minnesota timberwolves fan
the only way you know you're keeping
your franchise is that a-rod
and mark laurie invest in you know 100
million plus
renovation the target center or build a
new one that is the only
evidence you'll have that the
timberwolves will say otherwise
i'd be keeping my eye on seattle yeah
but garnett's going to get involved in
this and
kg wants to keep the team in minnesota
and how involved is he going to be
though
and i don't know you know i mean money
talks at some point and
if again it comes down to the arena like
the renter the target has been renovated
a couple of times
in recent years but it's i think 20 plus
years old
at this point which is right around the
time you start wondering if there's
a new arena if they build a new arena in
suburban minnesota
okay but until then i'm just gonna
believe that there's gonna be one eye on
seattle which is gonna get
more and more aggressive as the nhl pops
up there
and and it you know it starts to become
a professional sports town once again
thank you chris as always we appreciate
your time are you going to
call me tomorrow i'll
i'll call you the rest of your life if
you want me to wait will you call
tomorrow dan
will you call you won't call if if the
sons win
oh i'm i'm calling if the sun's win no
you have to worry about that okay
yeah yeah i mean you'll be texting chris
in boston christian boston comes
from hot from the uh the call caught
what
yeah thank you chris you got that that's
chris mannix
he's gonna be calling in tomorrow